hello and Vincent chin senior partner
and managing director of salvation for
the Boston Consulting Group this Asia is
going to be the new Nirvana for the
world we all know the statistics about a
billion people coming in to middle
income we all know the statistics about
the enormous wealth creation that will
take place here at a faster rate than he
has ever before in the history of
mankind but there are three challengers
or three unique opportunities that
confronts companies and countries and
governments in e changer the first is
for the first time in world history you
will have to economic superpowers that
are both rich and poor at the same time
what do I mean by that China in India
were both be economically strong and
powerful in absolute terms but India
country remains millions of households
that are still living below the poverty
line this is a unique situation for an
economically strong country second a lot
of the world's bludgers most successful
companies are from the West they have
not yet fully understood how to operate
in East Asia is it time for them to
learn or will these Asian companies rise
to the fore and become local and
regional champions and therefore
eventually global champions however at
the crux of all of this is the question
of human capital is human capital
development taking place at the pace and
at the quality that is required for East
Asia to truly achieve its potential so
the promise is there the question is how
do we do so and will the fundamental
problems of this region will resolve as
medicine thank you